Hey guys,
I'm on the road here and I just stopped because
I wanted to share this with you.
I've just read earlier today
that the world economic forum has just
said something that's crazy, that,
you know, it's the first time that we live in a
time where we create something that can create
new things.
AI.
AI comes up with new ideas and they
actually said that it can write a new Bible.
Where people will follow a
new holy book written by AI.
So, these things will happen the
closer we get to the end times.
Craziness is taking over.
But it's more important than
ever to stick to sound doctrine.
So, read your Bible.
Stick to it.
And make sure that you live in truth,
because if you don't, you live and practice a
religion that's just in your own head and made up.
So, let's stick to scripture.
Stick to God's word no matter what.
Love you guys.
Bye.